i remember one time i was in iraq doing
a military show and one lady hit me up
on social media
and uh offered to meet me in a blackhawk
helicopter
and give me a um
[ __ ] give me a little bit of oral
and uh
and i didn't do it man i got just too
nerved out you know it's a unique
scenario for sure yeah and i just didn't
know what protocol was i don't want to
be some dude
who looks like an insurgent or whatever
yeah you know because i have long hair
yeah so i just didn't want to this lady
was on the clock this lady was a bona
fide military woman really oh yeah now
did she think the [ __ ] offer in and
of itself wasn't going to be enough like
why did she sweeten the deal with a
black hole helicopter she just said the
flight is uh
the flight thing isn't secure tonight or
whatever so we could meet up in a
blackhawk and i'll give you a [ __ ]
but you weren't going to take flight
no no no no no maybe in here yeah maybe
in my head dude but yeah no but and uh
and also i remember this is this is the
part i feel worse about kind of is this
she had a huge either a animal had
bitten her on the neck or a huge acne a
huge one acne okay
and uh i was just like
i felt like it would almost be a game
show what was gonna buzz first
did you hear that
oh my god she had a [ __ ] ied under
her neck yeah so it's just now i could
sell a dangerous i could see now where
the hesitation came in yeah you know
because but if there were if that wasn't
there would you have been blackhawk down
on that oh yeah yeah yeah that's
blackhawk down yeah that's her version
she uh you know if the goiter if the
goiter wasn't there you would have had
that experience because that's almost
hard to turn down like it would take a
goiter or something like that to to to
thwart this experience i should not have
turned it down
god what an idiot because it's a good
story that it was offered but it would
be an amazing story
i think i was just so i didn't know if
we would be what if we got caught and
then i'm giving a bad look to this group
there was just some other implications
and dude some other lady don't if you go
over there for the military dude
somebody will they'll do sex with you
brother men or women
because they had people i mean out on
their morning jog stopping by
to see what was going on another lady
tried to come by and have sex one time
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you